Hello and welcome to week 0, here we are, this is "AV102 ESaaS: Managing Distributed
Teams".
We're run this course several times now so "welcome back" if you've joined us before
and "hello" if this is the first time.
So I've got access to the site here.
I can see more than you'll be able to see in the first week at the moment.
I've got a special staff view that shows me everything that's coming up. You'll be able
to see just this introduction.
I've got here like a little curriculum overview in my notes that I'll just go through.
In week 1 we'll focus on understanding the TA's role and we'll talk about how the TA
thing fits into managing distributed teams.
We'll go on to distributed software development, version control, cloud deployment, chores;
all these things, all this stuff that overlaps between being a TA for the 169 course; working
with industry software generally and also doing open source development.
Going into week 3, we'll cover soft skills, the team management, online scrums, meeting
preparation, these sorts of things, the communication technologies to use.
And then finally week 4 it's all about bugs and problems and how to handle the world when
things go wrong which is of course really what it's all about.
So I've got some administrivia here to go through.
Our team is all now thoroughly addicted to Slack chat which you may have heard of.
Slack has really surged in popularity over the last couple of years, outdistancing competitors
like HipChat, and I think a lot of that is down to their careful attention to user needs
and focus on making the interface friendly and easy to use.
In some ways this is just all an enterprise version of IRC, but the ease of use makes
quite a big difference.
Let's show you the interface
Here's the Agile Ventures Slack chat; we've got a number of different channels ... when
you join you'll be automatically added to a few channels.
General for general announcements, random just for random chat and tech talk for any
technical questions.
Then also we've got this ESaaS 169 MOOC channel, we've got an AV102 distributed team's channel
which you'll want to join.
One of the really nice things about Slack is that you'll get little alerts like this
when you get mentioned in a channel.
So I hope you're going to enjoy using Slack with us.
This course is a work in progress developed entirely by volunteers like you.
I just want to apologise upfront for any problems you encounter with our course.
If you do find issues with the course do get involved and help us fix them.
We can give you access to the materials and you can join all the other great volunteers
who are all alumni of the 169 course.
Please do jump in and help us out and please bear with us as we try to work around the
open source technology behind edX edge and the associated course management software
etc.
Speaking of things not working: my flaws; I'm Sam Joseph and I have many flaws, one
of them is that I just speak too fast.
I'm working on trying to improve that.
If I'm going too fast one thing you can do is slow down the videos.
In case you hadn't seen it there is a youtube feature to adjust the playback speed.
For example here's a little video from me with me talking very fast as usual and if
you find that I'm talking too fast then you can go and switch me down to .5 and listen
to me much more slowly.
We are also working on transcripts for our videos to make it easier to follow what I'm
saying, and again if you'd like to help us with those we'd be very grateful indeed.
YouTube and edX now have pretty good support for managing the transcripts, but there's
still quite a lot of work involved, so your support is very much appreciated.
So other things that I need to mention.
Next up there's going to be a video here with me talking more about what the course is about
then next week, we're going on to understanding the TAs role and we'll talk about who are
TA's and why do we need you for the 169 course.
We've got little quizzes here based on those videos talking about the TA responsibilities.
Before then we've got a very simple "start-off" homework which is just to register for the
upcoming 169 course and connect on the Agile Ventures Slack chat and make sure that you've
said hello there and you are all connected up and then we'll be able to start chatting
with you in the AV102 distributed teams Slack chat ...
So the course is sort of initially rather TA focused however taking this course doesn't
mean that you have to be a TA.
Of course we'd love everyone to contribute by being TA's in the 169 course which starts
in about five weeks from now but we'd just as equally like you to derive great value
from the topics we're talking about in terms of managing distributed teams and then use
that in your own work or help out in Agile Ventures rather than being a TA.
What is Agile Ventures I hear you ask?
It's a big project incubator that we have created; lots of more great work by 169 alumni
and we've got lots of active projects in there and people doing pair programming online together
and improving their coding and team skills.
We've got our big flagship project, here's the Harrow Community Network where we can
see a big list of all the contributors from around the world who've submitted code.
You can see a big lists of projects here; it's all about: "learn to code", "hang out
with cool people", and "save the world" by contributing to charity projects.
We've been having a lot of fun over the last several years doing Agile Ventures; anyway
more of that as we go into the course.
The course itself runs independently for four weeks and then runs in parallel with the both
parts of the 169 MOOC.
As we've done for the last few runs you can get certificates for completing the standalone
part of the course, and higher level certificates for supporting students as a TA in the MOOCs
and also for contributing to the open source charity projects within Agile Ventures.
The basic part of the course shouldn't be more than 3 or 4 hours a week.
Also there's Mentive who provide more comprehensive support to the MOOC students, and potentially
you can get paid as a Mentive Mentor, which is a great opportunity that I can supply more
information about if you are interested.
So I think there thats about it in terms of the summary; there are probably things I've
forgotten
but I'm sure I can pass those on to you before too long
anyhow if you want to know what this course is "really" all about then go ahead and watch
this next video from me,
all right, bye for now